you
let's see what we can make some magic
happen here three two one here we go we
got 62 at the start oh this guy is
always fast and furious he reminds me of
the Ferrari is he going to move oh he's
not only moving he's berserk he's so
quick he is so quick I don't like my
position I ready better get castle
before it's too late before it's too
late
speedy man he's super speedy man just
feel like I should try to time burn or
something okay let's do that Wow
and there's Forks and stuff yeah I'm
just crawling up into a ball Wow
I don't know what to do here I'm losing
threatening the rook I've made it way
too easy
made it way too all the mouse slipped
the mouse would say what are you gonna
do what are you going to do what an ugly
start I'll take the W however it comes
give me all the mouse lips shake that
one up shake that one off there you go
okay recover now that's you got one you
got that first round out of the way so
now it's time to go after the king all
right I'm gonna take that guy I know I
got some pieces stack on the e-file that
uh that's not too good
oh my goodness Wow let's shoot him away
still can't take the night cuz I'll lose
my queen all right they're in a pin that
are out of a pin
I guess we'll come over here prepare to
double I'm up upon probably do that no
matter what here no matter what maybe
yeah let's bully their queen again
threaten matin to Mono f7 move forward
take upon pigs they got her trade and
now we get pushing our ponds to Victory
Lane like racing kings keep going keep
going
uh-huh yep
I don't need my Kings help at this point
and we got it I can't keep going oh no
not a time ticker there we go they
resent okay ah
we're on streak now we're on streak we
got four somebody a berserk here two
three Sweeney Matt bro
let's try this that's some six not in
this variation that was Knight f3 okay
so we have some scotch and take my
knight take towards the center quick
hell
money for its poison though watch out
for Knight g4
alright let's enter Knight g4 back on Oh
Bill Gates Bill Gates its mate back to
tournament oh that was pretty quick yeah
I like this idea of knight c6 and E 5
and on a d5 push to transfer the knight
to the King side let's see if we could
make that happen
no another Scotch for Knights
all right let's take here and then pin
this guy threatening me for maybe take
towards the center if they take now
let's just eliminate him and I'll be
greedy I don't know if it's right hmm
I'll do it Queen to e2 Queen e7 Knight
f5 might have been a move I could have
tried for maybe for a quick let's try it
here this guy's doing is going after F 2
and H 2 shame on him okay light square
weaknesses Knight g4 again you can't you
can't mate on H 2 two times in a row
maybe you can or F 2 oh my goodness Bill
Gates oh here he is he's gonna bruise
urk yes he is alright he's too quick
he's just too quick alright I feel like
I could maybe survive he's thinking
about surviving it's not gonna be in a
pin is it bad that I'm not preserving
back hope not uh here I guess it's
awkward
take my knight Wow okay this is scary
yeah I'm ready to be in a fork
yikes would you slow down okay I'm
getting it
oh I'm getting fork is what I meant time
burner how much time came off with that
one oh I need to keep a tricky night
around if I'm to survive wow this is
crazy
this guy's crazy I could resign wow it
got simplified back to term and call
that too just call that two losses
against oh I've won the first one I want
only because it was a mouse the first
time that guy needs to slow down man he
needs to be tested tested for
steroids it's too fast too fast this guy
he's just slow down slow down
it's like that guy might be like Ferrari
on steroids Ferrari on steroids that's
how you know the guy is really fast okay
I'm joking I'm joking he's just really
good man he's really good what can I say
pointing at h2 again I'm going for the I
get a triple hat here triple hat tactic
all right let's get on the C file it'll
be pinned that's my very deep plan right
there it'll be pinned mm-hmm all right
they're pinned
I'm gonna go pawn grabbing I didn't
think you could do that cuz we got pins
I don't castled now I'm getting the
Queen mm-hmm yeah let's just take let's
see if they go g3 yeah okay light
squares have to go Castle queenside B 5
B 4 chase him away don't land in a fork
I should just challenge that night with
the bishop would have been easier okay
take care and I could move to eat what
just happened there I guess they
resigned they didn't lose on time did
they I don't even see what happened in
that one don't do that now you're in the
middle of a tournament don't analyze a
plucky okay 21 16 14 oh my goodness he
berserk me again crazy man
just crazy okay Castle they've only used
like three seconds
stop that pun you've gone far enough
okay I feel like this is a good position
objectively how can I not spoil it wow
this guy's scary man it's very scary
player okay let's come over here now you
know their bishops having a tough day
let's do this here and then maybe a
knight reposition I lied are they gonna
lose on time
wow they don't miss a trick man you
don't miss a trick can't take anything
okay I got that rope trade Wow
oh man then I'll slip back my knight
save the day save the day somehow Wow
crazy Wow mated oh my goodness that's
not the first time that's not the first
time not just in this tournament they
also had a maintenance and then they
lost from another turbit oh my goodness
unbelievable that guy needs to slow down
it's too much it's just too much
speechless I know it's just I'm on
repeat here you just just pointing out
the same things over and over yeah well
guys just lightning quick okay what's
happening on c3
okay we got dark squares making twos I
don't do the trick that's a quick win
guys
man wicked fast wicked fast okay 25 23
29 night do some damage that e5 pawn I
try to keep him there spearhead an
attack all right let's see if I can make
there C pawn flinch
all right I'll take that guy and then do
a little Knight shuffle actually let's
hang on to the c5 pawn with b4 yeah yeah
I got my rook protected so I can move my
a pawn like that I will improve my
knight that's on the second rank Bishop
d3 Oh let's keep a night there and okay
let's castle and take with the bishop
and play on the a file also what's wrong
with grabbing a free pawn tell me that
tell me what's wrong with that let's go
here yeah that's a good move I'm on h7 I
want to trade dark square ooh I was
thinking I was losing the exchange there
I'm just winning a piece I get push
because I have c5 defended my bishop
there is no trick c5 on rook takes
Knight push bishop can't stop so now a
little role reversal defend the pawn
with my bishop and then play knight here
to challenge that rep I think we got it
and it hits with a fork and then we
clean with check we got it back to
tournament what this has been ok 29 25
24 oh man so much time remains okay two
knights no matter what mmm let's not
drop material so quick let's wait so
later let's wait a little later to drop
that material just not right away
all right they Castle pretty quick
we're gonna hit him with this we're
gonna play Knight takes smash through
there in a pickle let's take what the
pawn queen g5 next Queen g5 Queen g3
move the bishop and get made on g7
mm-hmm why are you moving so slow oh my
god
why didn't I move the brain cramp Knight
move I go here I think now let's just
take him back cuz he could come back and
maybe do this I want to get Queen here
I'm gonna push e5 let's go here pawn
push then I go here oh they could take
this pawn with check that shouldn't
matter it actually will this was not
good maybe they'll resign thinking
there's no defense Queen here looks nice
defends everything they don't see it
unless they have a connection issue I
just I think they just don't see it I
know they didn't see it give a check
yeah they didn't they're not still not
gonna see it right you didn't see it
once you're not gonna see it again they
didn't see it that's sometimes that
happens okay 30 29 28 okay where am i
I'm 28 I'm about the halfway point no
take that guy develop and then get this
guy out
wonderful commentary oh I'm going to try
getting my guy out next time to develop
and then get this guy out all right
we're going caveman style move the Queen
so 95 doesn't hit with a fork let's blow
this open Queen g3 though puts a great
haul to everything alright alrighty
no you're gonna take huh alright I'll
push that guy and then my okay oh that
was good that was very nice that was a
very nice sequence right there
okay let's go here I don't want to allow
the rook to get to the seventh oh I got
to defend that I play Knight f4 Wow okay
I might have to abandon my bishop no
they can't I thought that they could
push that but that pawn is pinned that's
already sacked my bishop that was an
illegal move okay this one's too tight
too close here okay we got a pig chase
away the defender that Knights now that
Knight can't go to f4 take the bishop
it's restricted now I get here that's
pretty brutal
that's me whoa
I'll take that one that was a helpmate
35 33 32 whoo he just continues the
berserk
why isn't he preserving these games oh
oh I think you just finish we're gonna
get paired up or no around up maybe
thirty eight thirty five thirty - yes
this is the pack leader said I'm what
the Sicilian no no no I didn't want to
do that I try to take it back
Green Mile fans any Green Mile fans here
I tried to take it back but it was too
late Oh John Coffey John Coffey is John
Coffey who's saying that who's saying
who's Chuck coffee right now oh look it
up man look it up it's a sad movie you
will cry all right let's take like this
and then play against the Queen side
pawns I have a beautiful bishop he's
loving biting on all of his pawns here
staring at his own pawns all right I
don't want to drop my H pawn he's
important he's kind of important so a
little role reversal
he'll switcheroo here there in a pin
uh-huh bishop here
I'm entering oh no I'm not they could
take my bishop rook takes here they
would have won a piece I didn't see it
that happens rook activity King position
and over here oh no oh my Kings cut off
maybe that's a check
oh is it is that really a check okay my
Bishop's getting a workout Wow King
physician Brooke activity make up your
mind what's your reckon to do where do
you want to go let's take this guy so I
could question their king physician it's
a check these guys are found like
dominoes no lucky keep pushing trade all
right I got it
plenty of time back to tournament man 38
38 36 top two are not quite uh no
they're not on streak but I am I got the
fire I got the fire right there okay
maybe we'll get to do this little Knight
dance yes the Queen Knight drifts over
towards the Kings side and then we look
for me it's just like that starting with
this and then h5 or here these guys are
getting hit really hard now oh that's a
big problem I think that's a really big
problem Bishop takes pawn oh boy
it's crying out to be played here that's
me back to term it that was pretty quick
and I have a lead which is now tied and
I know exactly who I'm getting paired up
with now I think he just finished yes he
did yes he did he does not miss he does
not miss he only mouse slips hail me
mouse lips that's all I know
yeah see you must live with the sea pond
so I have a chance
all right it's too quick he's too quick
I'm speechless when I play against this
guy speechless oh let's prank with d4
there we go that's the path forward oh
they were trying to play b5 how sneaky
oh now I'm trapped oh my goodness too
scary man too scary
that's push oh my goodness wait I resign
they didn't freezer kin that one they
didn't berserk in now and I thought I
had a chance because they berserk no
that's not the case ah man and they were
the pack leader - mmm some of those
moves are too good some of those moves
are too good all right
let's go here take that quick kill this
is the stuff I've to resort to now not
quite there's still plenty of time I
still have my ideas though going for
these cheap tricks against the king
let's start with that I know h2 okay
they put a halt to that but this is
weakened I could have actually taken
there no no let's hit the knight see
what he does get here yes ooh I have to
do this otherwise I would have been well
I could have done that in another
variation
let's get castled ooh let's go here
first and then support
all right we'll do this even material
but they have better rooks for sure yeah
for sure we're gonna have to work some
magic to work some magic okay cut that
King off I need h4 in to eventually
gobble up some of their pawns with my
king Kings side so are they going where
are they going my Kings fast my king is
fast there's one pawn there's another
let's give a check get this guy here hit
both pawns and now I have two connected
pastors let's give a check and then come
back yeah I thought they might do that
sneaky sneaky 'no cinch up keep going
you got this okay I get to go here all
right don't lose this one don't lose
this one here we go
keep going right here here and then
Queen there got it back to Turman fifty
three forty two forty one less than
seven man pulling away he said has an
11-point lead now round up again okay
let's hit him with the the London let's
go let's try for a quick Queen to b3 if
I can move my pieces Queen b6 I play c5
all right now we're gonna play on the a
file maybe take a moment out to secure
my dark square Bishop and then do a
night journey all the way over that's
not a good move I don't think cuz I'm
threatening this I missed that I get
some material and I still continue on my
merry way to h a5 call it he can't
defend that pawn and then he gets into
d6
let's just take him out plug up the
e-file
alright I have to go faster okay that
creates some serious holes here secure
my darks for a bishop with that move
I'll take what the pawn take my knight
I'm gonna go here I'm gonna take my pawn
again or my knight okay so I'm crashing
through an a bishop takes next alright
they resigned back determined 58 44 41
less than six who fifty-eight 44 41
again
Oh is he dangerous he is one dangerous
beast no I need my knight right there no
I want to maintain my Bishop on c5 just
killing every IDI try to come up with he
preserved at least you know yeah just
run in reverse maybe it's your best
chance run in reverse uh-uh I'm on h4
they just see everything how are they
doing that how are they seeing
everything I don't know okay
okay I caught him on a free meal if I
guess Forks Wow too fast
Castle how about you castle
you could try castling at some point
right they already moved I didn't see
that they moved enter I just dropped a
piece what are you doing I'm gonna fork
why haven't you won this game already
gonna be in another fork
he's going to come back to defend
everything I'm going to do time burners
I can't even tell if they've moved
on time on time that's it this is an
ugly game you just oh my goodness
you just never even look back on any of
those games ever don't look back on
those games are just way too ugly fins
here's a shark and a half we're gonna
try the same tactic insta fins as we did
against Ronda we're gonna try and make
that happen secure my dark square bishop
and then rip to see one all right let's
not get forked here oh so rattled I'm a
dirty cheater has me rattled man rattled
all right let's close it up keep pushing
with b5 keep going I got to remove this
guy right here Bishop d3
let's take they could win upon maybe all
right ah I like my position how about
Queen here let's take him he seems more
important mm-hmm triple up all righty I
have a flight Square hmm I could give a
check that doesn't do anything though I
don't think a queen trade is good for me
so I'd rather drop upon in-betweener
take this pawn hope chess hope chess
you're going for now hmm
all right I'm gonna go with the exchange
sac when I took my bishop in I need to
keep the Queen's on I think keep the
Queen's on here all right I need to
enter the
hit the rook oh no that wasn't working
it's light time edge i junked him down
maybe secure my vicious position hm-hmm
watch out for me I just dropped my queen
time burners Oh back to tournament with
zero on the clock
oh that was so close that was so close I
dropped my queen oh oh man 60 48 47 I
have a one-point lead over third over
third only first oh man all right let's
continue to develop Knight takes trade
LightSquared bishop siz good got a
sneaking no i'm you're not sneaking in
one more buddy you're definitely not
sneaking in one more
okay let's trade light square bishop
can't rook here and reposition night I
got to get him out of here they have
some weakness on the diagonal for their
King remove their night mm-hmm let's go
here I like my Bishop Bishop to f4
flight square let's give the knight a
kick actually night here bishop here the
Knights pinned I could take here I have
enough on that okay and here stubble
they're doing good on I didn't want to
do that I want to go one square I have
him supported my Knights defending but I
just dropped that guy I just dropped in
93 hits
and back rank mate maybe they could take
that pawn out mmm let's give a check
come here time burners another time
burner oh I didn't even see that hmm I
guess I have to go after this guy takes
pawn to get behind him right away I got
him at least I should be able to get
this one on the clock oh man what a
tournament this guy beat me up bad oh my
goodness in berserk as well all right
final stand let me go to the final
standing 61 48 47 47 who else took part
in this one round or page 2 3 4 it
started off with 62 there's 97 at the
end so that was cool 41 through 50
almost there usually it's around around
60 so this was a very good turnout for a
created tournament all right
I like seeing this opposition this was
very good very strong players in this
field I'm a dirty cheater
finn's Ronda Bei Luke was here and then
I think exited before it even started
all right to the 97 of you who took part
in this good games all
you